yeah now uh well listen man you you've
been on a run and i think it's just dope
because like like you said you've been
consistently doing this [ __ ] for so long
and like to see it pay off is in one way
or the other it's like absolutely
incredible yeah yeah and you just told
me who was on this new album you got
coming with scram jones i don't know if
i could spill them no spell it man
listen you said ghost face killers on
you you're gonna hear it here first
because i haven't said it to anybody
else um but
the rise of the silverback
nems fully produced by scram jones
it's coming out
end of november probably no end of
october early november so we got
ghostface mm-hmm i forgot chic looch ooh
angie martinez she may or may not be
rapping
um
fat joe
gunplay okay uncle murder
dave east
petey crack shout out to state property
yeah these are all people that i've
always throughout the years wanted to
work with me i don't care if they're
buzzing now or what like whatever
i [ __ ] with talented people and people
that i [ __ ] with like their music and i
feel like all these guys brought their
[ __ ] best like ghost face
he laid a verse on there that was just
like sounded like [ __ ] first wu-tang
album type [ __ ] ghostface is a he's
about my fifth favorite mc of all time
he's in my top five he's definitely my
top five as well yeah most consistent in
in all of the of these absolutely yeah
supreme clientele is probably in my top
three albums
on apollo kids yeah that's that's i have
a playlist
that you know i made playlists just so i
could have in the car of so there's one
playlist of songs that say never gets
old like [ __ ] that i never get sick of
apollo kids is on there mighty healthy
is on there or might be deadly whatever
the [ __ ] might you healthy yeah yeah
yeah um
yeah there's a lot of there's a couple
ghost face joints on there
when you like reach out to ghost facers
the other way around like oh hey yo
pause
[Laughter]
so ghostface i'm on his album 36 seasons
okay so i put two verses on there so
he's [ __ ] with you i always have yeah
i always held that in my back pocket
like all right ghost you owe me a verse
i'm not gonna like press the issue but i
gave you two verses and i'm saying yeah
of course i got paid through the labels
and all that but um but then
ghost didn't know me at that time that
was put together by i think like bob
perry or somebody else but with ghosts
probably what i haven't listened to
when i see these random mutant albums
that look like the artist is not like
a hundred percent to be fair yeah but um
bob perry yeah i'm sure ghost had to
approve it of course yeah it's a bag
yeah yeah and there was an honor for me
because one song is just me a ghost the
other one is just me and cool g rap on a
ghost album ghost is not even on that
song that i'm on his album
cool g rappers only well first of all
that's incredible that you are on a
regular called second of all
g raps new album oh okay okay okay guys
you're on his new album yeah it's about
to come out oh wow so you're on two
songs with him so yeah it's full circle
you're on a ghost face song the ghost
face isn't on and you're on a cool g rap
yes
yeah um it's full circle you know why
because a lot of these people at the
time they may not this the 36th season
is from 2016. so nobody really he none
of the bigger artists knew about me but
through the years after i did that i
would see with ghostface he was showing
me a lot of love but then ghostface
you know i guess he started finding out
who i was and just really getting into
myself he was like your name is i got
you a hundred percent i just don't go to
the studio a lot but when i when i go
next time you top priority and when he
sent it i was like
well worth the wait
well worth the wait 100 it sounds like
vintage ghost face i was like yo he kind
of bodied me on my own [ __ ] that's a
good thing and that's okay you would
like that i'm not one of these i was
like yo yeah i tried to
body everybody that said yeah it's
called you know but when i'd rather have
a dope ass song
than
a mediocre song where i'm bodying
somebody else on it i i'm i'm all about
the the full product
yeah it's almost like you want if you're
gonna have ghost face on a song you want
to have the best ghost face possible
facts like if someone got a whole verse
and was like i kind of don't want hope
to overshadow like no it's jay-z exactly
like everyone's talking about this
khalid jay-z versus well you spent like
a hundred balls on that people forget
rick ross and little wayne's on and
that's okay yes absolutely cause jay-z
spit 100 bars exactly exactly
nah uh no that's crazy shout out to
ghost uh fat joe obviously hopped on the
bing bong remix um chic looch also a
silverback gorilla yo that's why i put
him he's on the title track rise of the
silverback is featuring sheik luch um
sheik
you know so he's uh he's with anybody
the gorillas he's a silver he's an
album's call silverback you know what
i'm saying so i felt like it was a
natural thing
and um
when that whole when we did the bing
bong remix
vinnie idol produced it and he's like a
d-block producer so originally i wanted
uh fat joe
busta and the whole locks on it
um
i feel like if we would have had more
time i would have got that
but uh styles sent this [ __ ] mad quick
and then you know jada was doing [ __ ] i
seen jada recently he was like i owe you
a verse i got you 100
um he was like i was supposed to do the
remix but i didn't get to it but i got
you um and sheik
he had ready had given me uh that verse
a while ago you know so he you guys each
have high level like disrespectful
violence in your yeah yeah like you and
chica are very high high levels both
about this i know i'm fatter than him
but he's both
just like random like objects getting
stabbed
that's dope though man so hopefully
scramjones get it together man no no
it's done but it's late october okay
okay okay it's done
yeah yeah [ __ ] with [ __ ] november yeah
later on
facts